well meantime president-elect joe biden
is announcing members of his coronavirus
task force today and one of biden's
first priorities in fighting the virus
may be a national mask mandate peter
ducey live for us in wilmington delaware
peter good morning to you
who are some of the members of the task
force
trace just hit our inboxes we've got
three co-chairs they are dr
david kessler dr vivek murthy the former
surgeon general and dr marcela
nunez smith they will head up this biden
kovit 19 effort as others in the
transition start to talk about who might
fill out
a president biden cabinet one of the
names that is floating around is pete
buttig but
something that these people have to
remember these democrats have to
remember is that
they might need some help from
republicans to get anybody confirmed
by the senate
mitch mcconnell is going to have to
decide whether he wants to
help move this country forward and
influence progress
or whether he wants to stop progress if
he chooses to do that
i'm fearful not only that the republican
party would pay a devastating price
politically but
that the american people would pay a
price that we can't afford to pay
because we
need action
so today the biden campaign is starting
to begin to try to turn all the big talk
about beating kova 19
into a plan of action fine advisors
though
also don't want to wait for the long
legislative process
to play out to undo trump administration
policies so they are starting to make a
list
of executive orders to sign on january
20th we have a little over 70 days jake
so i hope folks
give us a moment to pull it together but
i can tell you this that
throughout the campaign joe biden has
noted that
there are a number of things that we
need to tackle and do and that will need
to start
on day one yes that includes addressing
the climate crisis
and we do expect to see the uh
president-elect here in wilmington today
we also expect to see the vice
president-elect later on
uh we just watched as the press pool
that is assigned to travel inside of
their bubble
drove past to be swept at the biden
house here in wilmington
they are going to hold some sort of a
briefing
about coven 19 we don't know if there
will be questions at this briefing or if
it's just
us watching them be briefed by members
of their new covenant task force but we
will
be there as it all plays out back to you
i'm sure you will peter ducey live for
us in wilmington peter thank you